hello everyone and welcome to a most
interesting game that was played
yesterday in the Clarence Cup in the st.
Louis chess club at Juventud women's
world champion versus charissa we've
been following games of joy in June
during her Alberta Championship match
against Alexander Korea garage China
which she eventually won here in round
HQ faces curry Sahib she is the youngest
participant of the current cup and she's
the youngest woman ever to the to defeat
of grandmaster she defeated aleksandr
Iran over the age of 10 so really really
impressive stuff and well it's also a
very impressive game so without further
ado let's check it out
we've a four by jus in June and E 5 by
Yip we have Knight to f3 knight c6 and
Bishop to b5 again the Royal Lopez is on
the board a six goes for more fees
defense Bishop a4 and then out g6 at the
fianchetto defense we have deep sorry we
have d 4e captures on d4 and now C 3
offering yet another pawn which of
course you can grab what it could it can
get a bit messy for example captures
captures and now if you want to continue
developing as you normally would
Bishop g5 really could create some
problems for black if you don't want to
play something like f6 which usually
don't you don't want to go Knight f6
because of e5 for example if you go
night here then Knight d5 you pile up on
the night you threaten captures to win
the piece so then a lot of things happen
but India and white will always be
better but ok after c3 just continuing
development Bishop to g7 and now seek
after sandy for just grabbing back the
pawn are we have b5 pushing the bishop
back Bishop to b3 and only now Knight to
G to e7
with d5 by Jo engine Knights the a5
going after the bishop and now not
Bishop the c2 which seems like a
reasonable but rather Bishop the d2
putting pressure on the night forcing
this trade so ok
eeep goes for it with night cat for Sun
b3 Queen captures and b3 and now c5 a
very nice expansion you want to bring
your Bishop to d7 maybe c4 will be an
idea in the future and if it kept around
Poisson you don't
again anything you're just giving a more
central point for for a less central
phone so not really something to be
gained here
so after c5 we have brush up the c3 now
offering a straight of dark square
Bishop switch black can't really accept
it because if captures captures then you
have a nice double attack on the c5
point and the rook on h8 so here we have
f6
blocking the attack this way and now a3
preventing b4 we have these six
preparing to develop the lights for
Bishop and now there is one game where
Knight bTW - well there are two games
were Knight bTW - was played and there
is one game where Queen to c2 was played
but here we have h4 and it is a new move
in the position so already as a rule 14
we have a completely new game so let's
see how the game continues
charisa castles we have castles and now
if you continue with h5 to bust open the
position black will happily accept this
since your king is still in the center
of the board and well if rook captures
in Bishop g4 you might also bust open
the whites King side so white will not
be any happier about this than black
will so Knight B to d2 and now Queen t8
we have castles by Baiju engine and now
Bishop to d7 continuing development we
have Queen back to C to end now rook the
c8 putting the rook to the C file which
occupies the same as the Queen maybe
before will be an idea in the future
with b3 now making room for the bishop
here also maybe with ideas of advancing
the Ponte a4 with h6 and now a four so
look back the a8 preparing for some
trades along the a file captures
captures we have captures captures so
everything gets traded off and now rook
the a1 grabbing hold of the a file Queen
b7 getting the Queen out of the way and
now Queen to a2 also an interesting
approach would be b4
where you're basically saying if you
capturing captures then you're left with
a week be in the week D pawn so you're
probably gonna go for c4 and then rook
the a5 is very strong since you cannot
kick it away with nine Knight to c6 your
dark square bishop will be unable to
help out
now you're gonna go Queen a - you're
gonna bring the knight the d4 to help
out with an attack against the b5 or
maybe this night can also come and help
out with the attack of the b5 one so
that's one way to go about it
Jew goes for Queen to a2 instead and
okay
Knight to c8 the knife can now come to
b6 and 91 with B for pushing the bush
back butter back to be to ending out
Bishop to b5 grabbing hold of this very
nice diagonal we have night the c2 and
now the night thing come to III then I
can come to see for where it will be
very strong and now the shop the d3
putting pressure on the night and on the
ephod so tonight's the e3 as planned and
now Queen e7 with a double attack on the
e4 pawn and here very interesting move
by now but you in June Quinta sorry rook
to e1 which basically says okay you can
capture on e4 but if you capture on e4
then I'm gonna go Knight to e4 just a
nighty to c4 open up a double attack on
your bishop here and f5 now f3 is not
possible here because of Queen captures
on h4 and you attack the rook anyone
that's undefended but still what can go
for captures captures and then Knight
captures on e4 after pawn captures now
you deliver check King moves and now f3
does not win the pawn back but for
example after rook F for now you can
trade everything captures captures and
after captures captures you can go Queen
to f6 and now you will well your the g6
ponies under pressure the night the pawn
on d6 is under attack and here black
will most likely trade Queens captures
captures and now with the double points
even though you're up upon king of -
you're very close here you should you
should hold this to a draw without a
problem
so this is a Hydra vengeance plan if
mushroom goes for captures on e4 and
this is of course with best play however
a Carissa goes for night to b6 instead
there is always time to grab the pawn we
have Queen back to a1 and now rook the
a8 again grabbing hold of the a file
Queen back to c1 and the now h5 taking
away the g4 square from whites night
and now night eat the c-4 here waiting
with the g3 should have been played but
instead we have night eat the c4 which
now okay you're already defending this
twice but there's a problem
and Karissa finds at night captures on
c4 Knight captures on c4 and
rook to a2 in here you will have you
will have some problems defending
everything because the Queen is now
stuck guarding the bishop if you move
the Queen then just captures remove the
defender of the bishop and you lose the
you lose the bishop on b2 it's not it's
not a threat yet but you'll see what
happens here g3 was played and now comes
King to h7 sort of improving the
position of the King but not really here
it's it's very hard to find a good move
for black so feel free to pause the
video here sorry for white feel free to
pause of you here and try to find a
useful move for white while I give you a
couple of seconds just to get a feel of
the position so for those you who were
able to do it
congratulations on finding such such a
beautiful defensive idea it's really a
disgusting engine line so no harm done
if you didn't find anything but rook to
e3 is incredibly strong here because you
attack the bishop and you're inviting
Bishop to h6 but that's the point of
this line
Bishop to h6 now threatening to win
material f4 and only now Bishop captures
and b4 Bishop captures on e4 and now you
play Queen to b1 you you go for a double
attack and then after Bishop captures
and b1 rook captures on e7 with check
King g8 you check versa blocks and now
Bishop let's say captures an f6 and well
black is of course still better but a
white white definitely got some play and
this is the best you can do here however
Knight to d2 was played instead it means
that now the e4 pawn is nicely guarded
but you're welcome to pause the video
once again and now try to take advantage
of this nice study to move the best way
you can well I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it again congratulations it's still
Bishop to h6 for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show
there it is Bishop to h6 and now what do
you play here okay with f4 makes sense
you want to block the attack and now
comes the move you had to find the Queen
to a7 now lining up with the king the
thread is now just c4 check followed by
C 3 winning the game so you have to
block this Knight to c4 is plate and now
Queen back to b7 now the Queen can come
to g4 and put a lot of pressure on the
King side and the white will have
problems trying to defend everything
rookie 3 now okay you're already
guarding the g3 pawn but now the ship
captures on c4 b captures and Queen to
g4 so already you have a threat of
Bishop captures here because the the
Jeep on would be pinned and strongest
here is rook d3 which now defends the f4
pawn with with the bishop but then f5 is
incredibly strong he captures on f5 and
now Bishop to g7 so with a double attack
on the bishop and the bishop characters
on g7 now it's Queen e2 with mate mate
the follow so those are the poisons that
lurk in the position of course if Queen
f1 and Queen h2 is mate there's no
there's no getting around that
so after Queen to g4 already you see
there are problems here you should you
shouldn't really give up D 2 square so
King to H 1 was played instead now of
course the Jeep one is in pinned so the
Jeep on will be able to capture the
bishop so now feel free to once again
pause the video for the last time and
find the winning idea for black while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on paying attention it's
still Bishop captures on f4 for reserve
if you just want to enjoy the show
point is that okay now you're either
winning material and the game or G
characters and then Queen captures on h4
King the g1 now Queen g4 check and now
king - h1 king f1 doesn't help this
comes with check so it's pretty much the
same idea so king - h1 was played and
now Queen captures on f4 now there's the
simple threat of rook captures here
Queen capture
and Queen captures rook which basically
trades down into a winning Queen and
pawn in game and also there's this rook
to b3 which pretty much seems to guard
everything but not really Queen captures
Bishop captures and the rook e1 will now
pick up the bishop and again trade down
into a winning rook and pawn and game
because you don't have rook c3 due to
the b4 pawn guarding the c3 square so
after Queen captures on f4 Jew and June
tried going to be one to force this but
it's not well you don't have anything
better rope captures was played Queen
captures Queen captures on III and Queen
captures on f6 so now you're only up two
points but in a queen and point endgame
that's that's a lot Queen captures on e4
with check already you are now well you
are now up three points King H 2 and not
b3 you start pushing the beep on the b1
square is already covered so that that's
also a plus queen to f7 check now of
course do engines only hope is to create
some sort of a perpetual and she will do
her best to try and do that Queen f8
check King g5 Queen to d8 width check
into f5 27 check King a5 slowly but
surely re maneuvering the King Queen g7
check King f4 we have Queen to f6 check
and now came to g4 we have Queen to ECX
with check and now King sorry Queen
blocks with f5 and only now Queen
captures and these six but now it's it's
a very simple maneuver how to force a
winning endgame here just Queen to f2
check King h1 now of course Queen f3
check king h2 in the now Quinta h3 check
this is how he force a queen trade king
g1 and queen to g3 check and it was in
this position that the jus engine
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here
what follows is that you either lose the
Queen or you trade Queens captures
captures and then it's a race by the
race that white will definitely lose
these six B to d7 and now you promote to
a queen or a rook doesn't matter because
it's mate so white will never even even
promote yeah
after this Queen to g3 check 2 engine
resigned and an excellent victory for
young 16 year-old charissa yip against
the rainy
women's world champion Jew engine which
also takes revenge now she was leading
the tournament with hum pickin arrow but
now she's down a full point behind
behind humping Cornero so really
exciting stuff and a very very exciting
game thank you all for for suggesting it
I really do hope you enjoyed it we even
do have two photos by the official
photographer of the current scope the
Eleanor totus so here it is one of the
one of the photos of the of the in-game
you can see both of them really
concentrating on the position and also
here's a very artistic photo if you will
charisa in front and a blurry Juvenal in
the back thinking about the position so
there you have it once again I do hope
you enjoyed it I would like to think
Luke lost a Guam Lars Peterson
Prasanna Mongol Vader car just in
Paterson and Benjamin Golan for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
current events that are happening in the
world we are going to a forward with the
Paul Morphy saga and of course checking
up on your other excellent suggestions
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your Sunday